ans décidément les échanges de fichiers
audio et vidéo sur internet n'en
finissent plus de provoquer le débat des
députés dont certains font partie de
l'ump ont sérieusement amendé le projet
de loi sur les droits d'auteur discuté
en ce moment à l'assemblée
pas question pour eux de généraliser le
cryptage ou d'imposer les amendes record
aux internautes ils préféreraient le
paiement d'une sorte de redevance
mensuelle est ce qui a provoqué la
révolte de certains artistes et de tous
les producteurs appellent mostefa
olivier milloud deçà personnellement
minuit passé à l'assemblée nationale et
constat d'échec pour le ministre de la
culture son projet de loi attaqué à
droite comme à gauche le sera même pas
examiner jusqu'au bout je peux vous dire
que je ne ménagerai pas ma peine pour
réparer un certain nombre de fausses
rumeurs et de fausses informations
mesure phare du projet de loi les
sanctions progressives contrôle
internautes qui téléchargent ces
fichiers gratuitement sur internet
après un mail d'avertissement ce sont
300 euros damende puis 1500 suivi de
trois cent mille euros d'amendé trois
ans de prison pour ce qui ferait
commerce de cette activité
le problème c'est que mercredi soir des
députés ne l'ont pas entendu de cette
oreille et ont voté deux amendements
l'un pour légaliser le téléchargement
entre internautes
dans le cadre d'un usage privé l'autre
pour rémunérer en échange artistes et
producteurs avec un forfait
ce projet de loi est liberticide c'est
avant tout ce que nous avons dénoncé
puisque huit millions et demi de nos
concitoyens risquer avec ce projet doit
devenir des délinquants potentiels
projet de loi liberticide selon les un
amendement fatale à l'industrie du
disque selon les autres je me suis
imaginé cette licence globale à 4 euros
c'est-à-dire une rémunération ridicule
pour l'ensemble des oeuvres d'hier
d'aujourd'hui de la musique
du cinéma ça signifie que à partir de
demain
je n'ai plus les moyens et je n'ai plus
de modèles pour produire des artistes
les acteurs de ce dossier sensible vont
avoir les fêtes pour digérer tout ça
l'examen du projet de loi reprendra
mi-janvier alors